tél
et
alors comment on va barder très mal je
pense que il terminera peut-être pas
l'année
ça c'est une grande victoire les uns
auto sterling les autres verdun les
autres barbie j'admire toujours autant
c'est à dire non pas de la même manière
pour moi ça personnage historique
aujourd'hui a fait un historique dont on
voit deux avec la perspective les
erreurs les les réussites mais plus
d'une manière aussi proche et mao mao
c'est un peu la même chose aussi
avec cette différence que l'ayant
rencontré il ya côté affectif qui donne
et polpot c'est un ami à toi quand
j'étais étudiant il y a de cela
quarante ans et depuis de plus je n'ai
pas de nouvelles tu as bien connu aussi
erich honecker l'espagne pourtant
c'était dans le monde
il faut pas croire tout ce que dit le
monde
tu as dit dans le [ __ ] lumineux toute
ma sympathie va à saddam hussein
pourquoi j'avais dit ça au moment où la
guerre n'avait pas encore éclaté parce
que je pense qu'il posait un problème
qui est toujours posée c'est celui de la
répartition du pétrole arabe
il n'est pas admissible que les émirs et
les rois et dans les banques
occidentales
des sommes qui dépassent la dette de
tous les pillards et que si ces sommes
là était consacrée à l'industrie
industrialisation de ces pays que ce
serait un débouché pour l'industrie des
pays européens et la france en
particulier il disant cela donc je ne
préférais pas quelque chose d'
anti-france est au contraire tu étais
déçu par le non lieu dans l'affairé
boulin chez c'est une affaire dont je me
suis occupé à l'époque dont je me suis
retiré moi même
évidemment le de non lieu est décevant
tu regardes les jeux à la télé toi
parfois pas très saoul et celui là à
celui indices passion